let's start off with this
because this is because this is
interesting to me tonight
it's a little bit different
what is what is the definition so
there's all these depends on who
interprets you know like the notion of
what a sigma Mia is I think a lot of the
guys that are
more like mgtow like going their own way
they're they're kind of like Gap like
the ones that are choosing to go their
own way let's just put that with the
ones let's be clear because there's a
there's a part of the
demographics out there that aren't
choosing that direction it's kind of
like scent for them
but the sigma Mill that you find is is a
more internally focused sibling to the
alpha male so they're related apparently
while the alpha male quantifies himself
on his high position and social
hierarchy the social male sorry the
sigma prefers to forego the social
hierarchy and need for external
validation altogether and pursue
internal strength instead
it's interesting that sounds a lot like
me when I was growing up
essentially a loner or a stray man
although Sigma males have had close
Circles of friends and loved ones with
whom they should be catch Sigma males
not socially inept but simply socially
disinterested
also sounds a lot like how I feel about
what's going on with much of the stuff
of the world today I was you know I was
talking earlier I'm like sometimes you
just don't feel like I I actually belong
anywhere you know like you listen to
these these feeds I mean you can go down
this Rabbit Hole of of social media
feeds and it's like oh this uh
cross-dressing
whatever wants to read stories to like
children or you flip keep scrolling or
you flip up and in Finland they've got
some 50 year old dude that wants to
identify as the chick and dancing on the
ice and can't really skate it's like all
of these I'm sure some of you guys have
seen it today it's like I just you know
sometimes I just talk to the world like
I don't belong in this this is this is
not me so I don't know maybe I am a
sigma male so let's let's keep going
uh disinterested prefer solitary
activities where you're gonna have to
play social politics you can simply
focus on himself
specific male accepts that he does not
need power over others as the alpha male
desires but rather needs only power to
control himself and preserve his own
autonomy from other single males are
often pragmatic but may be seen as
others aloof paranoid secretive it's
selfish
what's up chat let's see uh if you guys
popping in Jerry Wayne Farooq Ernesto
how you guys doing nice to see you all
guys do me a solid if you're watching
this somewhere else on the interwebs I'm
just going to copy and paste and just
drop in here on all the chats so if
you're on the Twitter the twatches the
Facebooks the whatevers head on over to
YouTube subscribe to the channel hit the
like button for the algorithms thank you
kindly the um I'm going to do q a today
as I always do I'll drop the link about
halfway through the show a lot of people
DM me how do I how do I ask a question
and hit the join link when I drop it
it's not complicated it's pretty
straightforward
all right so
the thing that kind of bothered me when
I was sort of diving into this and
looking at it is that
I kind of came from an introverted
background maybe I was a sigma male who
knows but
everything that you accomplished in life
that leads to Greatness
and these milestones in your life you
can't do it by yourself okay
um
the reason why sapiens are so successful
as a species is due to gossip that's
that's due to us collaborating and
communicating with each other so as much
as you might romanticize the idea of
don't bother me leave me alone I'm
perfectly fine alone stay out of my way
um that can work but I still think you
need a tribe so I wanted to get into
this
um document that I pulled up from a
psychologist's site and he breaks down
characteristics and traits
of sorry he calls he's a 17 traits of
Sigma males uh one independent so single
males are direct they rely on themselves
companies okay but they don't need it
too much they may have a couple of close
friends but they don't need a large
Social Circle and are content with their
own company and don't like wasting time
okay so
I actually I agree with a lot of that to
be honest with you too elusive
um the words mysterious elusive hard to
reach often used to describe a sigma
male it's not their particularly
secretive it's just that they don't
engage in finalities and they don't like
to overshare their life okay kind of
like that too rich why don't you share
this why don't you share that because
the internet's freaking weird dude and I
don't want people knowing about my life
in detail
maybe I am a loser maybe help hang on
this might be the title of the next book
instead of the unplugged elf it might be
the unplugged sofa where are we getting
here
Off the Grid
because of their character traits Sigma
males are less likely to be on the web
they write that's not me for sure I'm
all over the goddamn web they recognize
his benefits but rarely see the need to
engage social media all the time they
see the media's helpful tools to connect
but also understand it can drain time
deep thinkers
Ponder the Deep questions in life they
wonder why we are here the purpose of
life I don't do any of that stuff
how to live a good life definitely
because of their depth they often reject
much of what society says and does yes I
agree with that the test shallowness
Sigma males the test superficial
superficiality and shallowness that's
usually why they dislike groups in small
talk and why they keep themselves keep
themselves to themselves they take life
too far too seriously to engage in
life's trivialities
um
sounds like a peaceful life charismatic
because of their elusiveness quietness
and Independence many people find them
quite charismatic sigmas are silently
confident and that has power but they
are dark horses and lack their desire
for social approval makes them stand out
dominant differently so it says
differently dominant Alphas dominate
through their lab Behavior hostilities
showing off I don't know that Alphas are
hostile it's a exaggeration segments
dominate differently they get what they
want without others noticing
um okay now let's get interesting they
can be excellent in networking as people
respect what they say brooding is the
next one some say sigmas are brooding
they are undoubtedly quiet and rarely
speak unnecessarily their moods are
often darker and it's not they're not
happy or optimistic they are just not
superficial they favor practicality over
positivity
definitely introverted traits
you guys don't know this if you're new
to the channel but I was quite
introverted growing up like you know the
existence in my high school years very
small group of friends listening to a
lot of uh Rock heavy metal you know long
hair head bangers sort of dude went to
concerts with a very close uh select
group of friends I get it like I get
like I think I'm I'm I'm getting with
the sigma male archetype is sort of
about uh they use critical thinking as
the next category
um they think critically about what
others tell them and whether it is
formed sorry from teachers parents or
co-workers and even stuff that they read
on the web they recognize critical
thinking skills are crucial to getting
by in the world I like I would agree
with that like common sense is just not
common anymore people are pretty stupid
nowadays and they just you know like
what what was it three quarters of the
population that just oh yeah just give
me that give me that juicy jab you know
the untested uh experimental thing
number 10 Embrace ambiguity super males
are happy that's kind of like amuse
Mastery right
happy happy with uncertainty they don't
need the world to be black and white
they recognize the supplies to many
spheres including what is real and what
is right they still have preferences
like anyone else but don't hold on to
them too tightly no slave to Fashion say
women else don't care too much about
what is fashionable they are far too
independent and practical to care well
if they don't care about what other
people think why would they care about
fashion right
they like to look good in the Embrace
their style but pay no mind to what is
popular
they don't fit in super males rarely
find themselves as part of groups that
can take part in
them if it suits their needs but they
will never be a full-time member
something about the dependence of a
click puts them off
introverted definitely adaptable signal
males adapts different circumstances
because they reject see this is where
this is where you're going to run into
some problems with some of the guys that
think that they're
like the Lone Wolf sort of character but
they're not adapting to situations
because I see I see a lot of guys say
well I'm just going to go over here and
do my own thing and mind my own business
and Go My Own Go My Own Way sort of
thing but they're not adapting to the
current circumstances in their
environment
so sugar Mills can adapt to different
circumstances because they reject much
of what society says everyone should do
they often don't follow the same paths
everyone else yet sigmas don't like to
stand out and attract attention to
themselves so they learn to adjust and
blend in
dislike rules
okay I'm all about a little more freedom
in life not uh anarchists but they do
obey the rules and where the rules are
not transparent the rules seem trivial
and pointless and nobody's getting
harmed they move you they may choose to
sidestep them
I always say it's better to ask for
forgiveness than to ask for permission
so that's kind of a line with the number
14 dislike rules constraints is the next
one sigma's the test that one others try
to control them and why others often see
them as Rebels many see society's rules
as a subtle form of control and so
choose not to follow blindly thus Sigma
celebrate freedom and fight things that
hold them back
that's counterintuitive because if
you're going your own way going like I'm
over here leave me alone
fighting things that hold you back I
don't know
travel lightly sigmas are not impressive
material wealth while the alpha may be
striving for money status to show off
the power of the sigma male is content
with what he has see this like I've
often asked people would you rather be
um rich and anonymous
or famous and poor
or Rich and Famous
and
if you're to pick out of one of those
here let's you know let's do a quick
pull let's see this is a poll let's see
what you guys in the chat are saying uh
because I think the polls still work
here yeah I'm logged in
so how do we do a pull
pull come on start a q a startup poll
there we go
so would you rather
be
let's go with uh rich and a non
rich and famous
there's no point in saying famous and
poor because if you have the choice of
being rich in a non you're of course
going to pick that so let's just pose
those two questions it's in the live
chat
Roy says Rich it's sexy yeah I pick rich
and sexy too all right let's go back to
this article you guys you guys can click
on that poll take a look at it in a
second
they travel lightly not impressed with
real wealth okay prefers is wet
intellect and is cutting to any material
possessions they have no plans is the
next one signal finds it hard to
dedicate themselves to one thing for any
length of time they have many things of
interest to them and can be involved in
different activities often they are very
exciting life but not single Midas today
yeah okay yeah so
I don't look man life requires planning
like there's like there's some things
that I deviate here from like you need a
tribe right like you the way of men is a
way of the gang as Jack Donovan would
would uh say right so like the
like the almost full disconnect it's
more of a disconnect than I think is
useful to you as a guy
I mean I put it to you this way I don't
think the unplugged Alpha would
disconnect from a network of metamine
part of the I mean one of the reasons
why I have my networks of men is so that
when things come up things that need a
sounding board uh feedback I need help
with something I can go there and they
can Co and they can go to the other
members in the group too that's why I
created this thing right I really hope
you guys enjoyed that clip if you want
to watch the full length podcast you can
find that over here that clips from if
you're new to the channel make sure you
hit subscribe over here and pin down
below in the top comment you'll find a
bunch of useful links to my website my
supplement line books and a bunch of
other stuff have an amazing day peace
out